i taught english in spain for a little
and so i still had
these spanish teachers that i was
friends with and then i didn't talk to
them for like three years then i got snl
when i was on the news in madrid they
were like racist comic
like
they all started hitting me on whatsapp
like shane what the what happened like
you're racist i was like
locieto amigos
[Music]
so
[Music]
this week on forward one of the funniest
people on the internet one half of
gillian keeves and someone i have a
little bit of shared history with shane
gillis welcome shane i'm happy we
finally got to actually sit down yeah me
too so you and i spoke
back in 2019 uh and so
you know i just want like if people are
like shane gillis that sounds vaguely
familiar and you're an andrew yang fan
so to re-cast this september 2019 some
very exciting announcements are made
about the new cast of saturday night
live it includes
bowen yang chloe feynman and shane
gillis and so you are exultant for
approximately how many hours
i probably had 24 hours because i knew i
was gonna get uh i got the call that i
was gonna be on the show a day before
and then when yeah once it got announced
i probably had about
six hours didn't take them long okay so
then six hours later news came out that
you had made some uh offensive comments
on a podcast maybe like you know x
months earlier
about me personally i was on there and
then other groups i think asians were
certainly on there maybe maybe some
others i think all of them for sure
i mean every group every group so they
got me on asians though seemed like like
i just heard about the asian thing yeah
which is a it's a funny thing to get me
particularly for one thing because then
it seems like that's like something i'm
actually like
you know what i mean now it looks like i
just i'm a guy going around like [ __ ]
i hate asians it's like no dude well you
know what i mean i'm you know
it does make sense because that's the
way i remember the news coverage and
that's obviously how it came to my
attention
so uh i see this and then i'm like okay
who the heck is this guy and my wife's
like who the heck is this guy so we sit
down and watch some of your comedy and
pretty quickly conclude
that you're not some like you know
malignant
uh
rancid like ranting type yeah that you
seemed like a comedian
uh and at that time i made a statement
saying look like i don't like some of
this humor
but no one should lose their job over
making comments on a podcast you know
and i didn't say this at the time but i
was like podcast said frankly no one
[ __ ] heard yeah like no no it's like
no one listened no no no one listened
and so someone took the time to be like
okay hear these things
you're an up-and-coming comedian i
thought that in this case it was like
look uh and at the time even when i made
this statement i didn't think that they
would listen
but i said
as someone who is personally slurred
i don't think that this is something
that someone should lose a job over yeah
and
and then uh so during this time what's
happening to you
oh um yeah just getting
canceled
and so what is it like
what do you say being crushed so the
news stories start coming out and then
what happens
uh you just start getting like
every tweet ever like i mean i was
number one on twitter for like three
days just getting because there was a
debate that was the hard part was like
there was i understood both sides of the
argument like i i think everyone did
like he should be fired or he was just
joking so you go from the highest of
highs probably calling your parents
being like hey guess what like you know
yeah that was the first thing i was ever
able to like tell my parents in comedy
that they understood you know normally
be like oh i'm featuring this weekend
for
so and so they'd be like who cares this
was the first one i was like i'm going
to be on saturday night live they were
like wow wow i'm proud of you
yeah you know and it must have been a
number of years to lead up to that point
and there were probably times when your
parents were not exactly pumped about
your choices
um so to rewind a little bit you played
high school football
you attended west point on a football
scholarship is that right yeah but i
mean they they give you full rides
no matter what at west point but yeah i
was there to play football so at this
point and the reason i'm casting this is
that your parents are probably pretty
proud well they were proud no they were
proud then and then i got there
quit cried did they you know you can't
cry in boot camp they don't like it that
was a big baby and i went home
uh so yeah they were pretty disappointed
so how many years was it before between
you're saying hey i'm gonna give comedy
a try and then you're being able to call
your parents and say hey mom and dad
guess what i'm gonna be on snl
eight or nine years yeah so i mean that
that's that's a tough stretch i'm sure
and then when the negative
coverage started coming out um you
probably read that article and you're
like okay like and then you start
trending on twitter so
i was i went to go do stand-up that
night and i was like oh this is gonna be
the coolest night ever all the comedians
are gonna be like hey there he is you
know so i'm on the train from queens
going into the city and my agent calls
and i was like did you say
dexler and i was like no like i was like
i wouldn't say that i genuinely i was
like no i don't even why would i say
that
and then she was like here's a video of
you saying it i was like holy [ __ ]
and then
so you know how it is riding the train
you lose service
so i would lose service for like five
minutes and then at the next stop get a
million texts that are like holy [ __ ]
you're you're [ __ ]
yeah so i got like gradually cancelled
every stop
it was it was crazy it was surreal it
was totally surreal
i don't know how to really describe it
i'm not like by the way i'm not i wanted
to be clear i'm not a victim
like i'm not like sitting here like oh i
can't believe what they did to me it's
like
no there's a video of me using a slur
it's like there's going to be some
backlash yeah oh so and it's one of the
things i i've appreciated about your
time since and a lot of people might not
know this but you haven't frankly
responded in the way a lot of people do
if they are the recipient of like a lot
of energy which is to go to whatever the
opposite of that energy is
yeah i tried to make sure that because
that's how that's how it really like
getting canceled or however you want
consequence whatever uh that's how i
think it really
gets you is if you let it
become who you are you know
if you like start fighting against it
being a [ __ ] did you have that
perspective immediately or or what was
that yeah i think so i think i always
had that
because it's also just not who i am like
if i was a
closeted alt-right dude
and they outed me then it'd be hard to
fake you know but i was just i don't
know yeah if anything you're humor i
mean i'd call it middle of the road um
but a lot of your stuff you're kind of a
high-level trump impersonator yeah i got
that good yeah
which obviously is poking fun at trump
like an awful lot um and i think a lot
of your humor is actually poking fun at
yourself it's something that if someone
decides to check you out they can see
that's one of the running themes
[Laughter]
so around this time um i my team puts me
in touch with you and i have a call with
you during our phone conversation i was
like okay like i felt good about
the statement i made saying like look i
don't think this guy should should lose
his job
yeah i really
really appreciated that for real like
that was like i was like damn this guy's
awesome
social media is attacking you like uh
are you getting updates from your agent
in a particular way uh does someone yeah
non-stop just on the phone for like four
days straight
just taking phone snl nbc my agents my
management people trying to do
interviews all that so i don't remember
you doing interviews i didn't i didn't
because i think
i mean it was never going to be good
at the time it was never going to be
good
i didn't want to talk about
comedy
like i'm too new at it still so for me
to like pontificate about comedy makes
me feel uncomfortable you know to just
try to like quote patrice o'neill and be
like every
good joke is born from a bad attempt
something like that the thing is that
that sucks with mine was it was a
podcast so it wasn't like a well thought
out
smart joke it was just talking
and i said the wrong thing and then when
did you start having the sense okay
uh they're going to rescind this offer
slash i'm going to i kind of knew from
the start like right away i was like
there's no way they're going to let this
go this is especially snl snl's it's one
of the few jobs where they'll definitely
fire you for that and it's one of the
few jobs that people will look into your
past when you get it i could have been
hired for most places and no one would
have cared is there anyone on your team
saying hey maybe if we do xyz oh yeah
everybody was coming up with
you should do this do this try this so
what were those ideas um it'd be like
let's do a this guy from the new york
times wants to write an article or a
profile or something and it's like oh
i'm just gonna put my life in this guy's
hands be like hopefully he writes
something good but did the people close
to you advise you to do it everybody had
different ideas no one knew what to do
no one knew it was a sinking [ __ ] there
was no
i was the only one that was like it's
over you know what i find myself
thinking um because it did seem like the
attention was primarily on
um
your comments about asians
i wonder if there was like an equivalent
because periodically people screw up
with particular groups and then they go
and be like look i insulted this group
i'm now going to get abs like absolution
slash understand standing slash educated
but did anyone say to you it's like hey
is there like you know can we do
something that's gonna yeah but that
seems i don't know i don't like i don't
like when people do that i don't know it
seems weird to me like like like bill
maher said the n-word on his show and
then the next week i think had ice cube
on now ice cubes gotta
enlighten me in front of the whole world
it's like a weird
i don't know it seems phony to me you
know i know i didn't
mean it so it's hard for me to be like
now i need to re-educate myself it's
like no dude it's
that that's probably very genuine and
often the case in a lot of these
instances where the person like you know
what what it is when you say it seems
phony for a lot of these people it's
like look the team says like this is how
you get out of this this is the pr move
uh like that yeah they they'll
give you an apology to tweet
like a company will or your agent or
somebody will be like here tweet this
and it's like no i'm not
that's crazy so you were given that sort
of i was given an apology like template
and they're like tweet this i was like i
can't so um so this is actually in a way
like extraordinarily
principled of you in a way it's like you
have people who are meant to be minding
your professional interests being like
look this is going to be best for your
professional interests
and then you look at it and say like i i
can't genuinely put my name to this
because that's not actually
what i like what i am thinking at this
moment yeah
it was hard
it was hard and also the thing that hurt
me was i had no no one knew who i was
there was no previous thing to like look
back and be like no he's funny
no one had any idea that was the only
clip anybody had ever seen
so it was like that is unfortunately
probably accurate yeah you built up a
body of work since then yeah that i do
recommend people check out because it's
genuinely smart and funny thank you like
you're talented so snl
it may be one of the highest watermarks
in comedy and they thought you were
funny enough to be there yeah and so
there that has to feel good yeah that
was cool
that was cool to go straight to cast
that was cool oh yeah it was cool yeah a
great six hours apparently it was a good
six hours
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
ever since i was a kid i was kind of
into my brain
like i wanted to do good things for it
one of the best things we can do is
exercise you can get some outdoor time
but some of us need a lot more than that
some of us need genuine therapy and now
there's better help online therapy that
can lend us a hand from the comfort of
our own home just the way that we need
it i saw a therapist when i was a
teenager in school and have been a huge
believer
ever since better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat online therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to and you can be matched
with a therapist of your own in under 48
hours our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
yang that's betterhelp.com
yang get better help today you'll be
glad you did
[Music]
you grew up in pennsylvania yeah were
there a lot of asians around where you
grew up
no like do you remember any in your
school yeah there were a couple
so i went to a school like that
where i was one of the couple
there was like one per year so growing
up in that environment for me
and this was i'm older than you so this
was like the 80s when there were only
like three tv networks and the rest of
it so there were very very few images of
asians of any kind like the most
prominent ones that anyone would know
would be bruce lee jackie chan wasn't
even a thing at that point this was like
pre-rumble in the bronx rumble the box
came out went to a movie theater and i
was like you know jackie chan's made it
to the states so i got
uh teased about being asian
like all the time as a kid yeah
um and as a kid it was difficult uh and
i'd skipped a grade so i was like
scrawny and smaller yeah
and so there was like a lot of this like
um anger that built up in me honestly so
the the thing that happened to me
growing up was like i thought to myself
okay i can be the
chinese guy that takes it or i can be
the chinese guy that
[ __ ] fights over it yeah and so i
chose the latter
and i lost most all of those fights
because i was the scottish
guy
but the the teachers and administrators
tended to punish whoever i was fighting
with
because they just assumed that like oh
it must be the other kid's fault yeah
and it actually got to a point sometimes
when it was not the other kid's fault
like sometimes i would just be like
you're just like it's time to fight oh
yeah it's like or i would be it was not
i mean i'm not happy or proud of it but
part of it is that i was very conscious
of being one of the only asian kids
growing up um it gave me a chip on my
shoulder
and then
i went to uh both a prep school in my
case in a college that had a much higher
like you know number of asians probably
higher than normal and you live in
queens now right yeah which is like i
mean it's very diverse yeah
like literally literally where you live
might be the most diverse place in the
entire country so i've got two boys or
nine and six and sometimes i look at
them
to try and figure out what their
experience is like and how similar
dissimilar it is to mine and it turns
out it's completely dissimilar uh like
they don't seem conscious of
their race in the least yeah my per
perception or response to it has evolved
over my lifetime
um but also like the times have changed
a little bit
like i mean times might have even
changed since
um since 2019 when we're having this
conversation yeah i think 2020 when
covet happened then like anti-asian
stuff did start getting
more
like dark and
venomous and
even violent in some cases um you know
like like
here in new york where i i've been most
of the time you did have a different
energy it's like the first time in my
life
where i felt
like
uh like being asian actually
made you more of a target uh and for for
more than just like you know
snide comets or whatever the heck yeah
um
i mean i know asian women
in particular who literally try and make
themselves look less asian when they
leave the house jeez
they're like putting on sunglasses and
like rapping
themselves
yeah it's really dark yeah it's it's
pretty disgusting growing up asian in
this country like you don't
expect at least the way i grow up like
you don't expect people not to see that
you're
asian because it's like obvious yeah and
you don't even expect necessarily for
them to
not make certain associations like i'm
not someone who gets hyper reactive to
people's statements in large part
because i grew up in an environment
where people are just saying
[ __ ] to each other all the time
and i i think about the kids i grew up
with and like would i run to them now
and be like you're racist be like no
there were
would we would friends give each other
[ __ ] about
you know something about their
background or identity all the time yeah
it makes sense if you've been around
white dudes
talking [ __ ] you've heard of i don't
know i guess that's what you're trying
to say right
a little bit it's like you're a little
more accustomed to it than
because i remember i remember my high
school yeah we did almost no minorities
but when they were people i mean people
definitely such it
and i don't think it
it sounds ridiculous but it wasn't like
hateful
you know what i mean oh looking back at
it it's like
jesus christ
that was crazy this is one of the things
that i genuinely don't know shane and
i'm trying to figure this out
if you and i went to a high school today
yeah like does the stiff
stuff still go on i don't know i think
they're no i think they're very serious
about it maybe i have no idea i haven't
been in school well again it's one of
the reasons why i look at my kids
experience trying to figure it out
because there are times when i feel like
i had an experience be like oh like i'm
out of date
and one of the things that
certainly i stand for
uh is that people can make a mistake
and then they should be allowed
move on acknowledge that mistake or
sometimes maybe say like look like you
know uh maybe i'm not going to do the
pro forma things although the yeah
social media doesn't help
social media is the worst i mean right
right now if someone wanted to make
either of us look like [ __ ] they could
produce
like a 60-second long montage of
us doing you know very unfortunate
seeming things
out of context i've done stupid stupid
things for sure in their defense too
i am
sitting in front of a camera recording
it and doing it
so that's another you know aspect of it
where it's like i am putting it out
there
so there is a you know
it's like i said something stupid so
what it's like well i did record it and
post it on the internet i mean that this
is obviously going to be a byproduct of
the age we're in but i think that
they're going to be a lot of people that
are going to have a hard time
transitioning to let's say running for
political office
uh because there's there's all sorts of
digital history of them doing things
we're like hey i can build this like i
know
people i'm trying to get to run for
president right now some of whom are
comedians some of whom are not
trying to get a comedian to run for
president uh i mean there are a couple
that are at least looking at it
actually i've been asking comedians this
who would be your number one draft pick
as a comedian to run for president
i think
overall you'd probably say somebody like
jon stewart john stewart's very very
high on people's lists yeah it's got to
be him right
so that's one of the most popular um who
else do people say people people say
chappelle but they know he won't do it
and i no he won't go and do it he won't
do it someone said al franken um the
other week and that one actually makes
sense yeah because he's been a senator
he probably he was close i think he
would have probably run right he
probably would have run yeah it would
run and he would have done well and when
i talk about this sense of uh
forgiveness and understanding
al franken would probably be at the top
of most people's list because that dude
got drummed out of the senate during
like a very emotionally charged time
yeah and there was no due process it was
like hey guys let's have like a hearing
and like sure investigate and people
like no you out and then he was like
you know he was left with very little
choice um i think there are a lot of
people that were great it would have
been nice to have him against trump on
the debate stage well he would have been
able to handle that okay so i was on
i was on a panel
a number of days ago with chris christie
who now people
are down on for various reasons but
sitting with him he was both talented
and funny yeah and he made a case to the
folks that were there it was like hey
you put me on a debate stage with donald
trump like i can really do some damage
um and listening to christy talk about
this i was like he actually could
because he's been around him a lot he's
kind of comfortable and he's got that
kind of manner so when you say al
franken would have done the same like i
i think that there is
some real
merit to having someone with
comedic experience and abilities
uh particularly if if uh you're running
against someone like trump trump
actually has a lot of those he's very
funny
he's undeniably funny yeah i i honestly
i think he's undeniably fun oh i mean
he's no he's entertaining for sure he's
got uh he's also an incredibly
experienced performer yeah proportion of
politics that is performative is now sky
high yeah
uh and so if you have these performers
you have these political performers and
a lot of people are tuning out that sort
of performance now like there was a
theory i had that we're in like a post
inspiration age where if you come out
and you're like inspirational um like
obama like now that stuff like you know
doesn't work as well because they used
it up they did it so often with
everything
everybody was trying to be inspirational
like it'd be like is it is that it's
like you know it'd be like oh great a
significant proportion of them almost
seem like they're imitating obama too
because that's the
for sure
and it doesn't seem to work
no and now there's going to be a
probably a wave of dudes imitating trump
which
that's tough to pull off
he's one of the only guys i think that
can do that
which is get away with everything oh i i
a thousand percent agree with you that
trump is going to spawn a whole legion
yeah uh of which will be fun to watch
for imitators it'll be funny
to see guys try to be mean on the debate
stage
that would be fun well there was a
moment in 2016 when marco rubio tried to
imitate trump and it was just it felt so
flat near the city it doesn't work um
you have to to be able to pull it off in
a certain way
jeb started chirping back and he got
crushed he was like you're high energy
tonight chad i like that i was like oh
so [ __ ] good at talking [ __ ] and
everybody else had to play by the
political rules everybody else had to
don't be rude
be a politician be good and he's up
there just bullying people over running
them yeah
here at forward we recommend expressvpn
to safeguard your data give you control
and anonymity why let these big tech
companies follow you around wherever you
go but one other perk to using
expressvpn is that it can give you
access to content that's available in
europe in asia and other parts of the
world that's not available to you
because netflix or other services say
hey your servers in the united states of
america with expressvpn you can beam
into any part of the world
anytime and access content and the
entire time keep your data safe and
secure and to yourself use
expressvpn.com
yang to give it a try don't forget to
use my link at express
expressvpn.com yang to get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
keep your data to yourself become
anonymous to the big tech companies and
all the content in other parts of the
world you want
expressvpn.com yang
[Music]
this really is
right now not to make too much of it but
it's sort of my life's work right now so
check it out you have uh the democratic
party establishment who are like hey you
gotta play by these rules like we're
gonna act a certain way we're like
buttoned up and we have uh a certain way
of presenting by the way i ran for
president uh in this crew and then you
have the republican party under trump
that's become this anti-institutional
[ __ ] everything burn it down kind of
energy
uh and there's a republican
establishment within that yeah that
fought trump and lost and now trump
yeah now everyone's going along with it
you know there has to be a kind of this
positive ex-institutional energy that
comes up
and ends up being like this third force
in american politics so my paragon
example of this
is someone like matthew mcconaughey
like
so mcconaughey is from outside the
institutions
but he's not an [ __ ] like in the same
way trump is yeah uh and so i look at
someone like that and thank god like
that's the kind of figure that we need
to get us out of this mess
now there are certain people over here
that i think that's where we're at
you know can you imagine as a country oh
i can't imagine ten years ago ten years
ago probably not hopefully matthew
mcconaughey can get us out of this mess
it's like oh man what are we doing so
you can fill in figures for matthew
mcconaughey mark cuban's in this
category yeah the rock is in this
category
some would say oprah oh wait so you're
yeah i'm laughing i know i know it's
just it's it is funny that this is where
we're at it's like hopefully the rock
can team up with matthew mcconaughey and
defeat trump and save america it's like
damn i mean i certainly think the odds
of that are much higher than joe biden
defeating trump joe budden's
gone he's gone
right there's no chance
i mean i think there's uh a likelihood
he ends up the nominee if they do that
they're again they're trying to lose
so you should know man i've gone through
this logic
uh so you and i if they ran today again
trump vs biden
trump would win
i agree and if they do desantis or
whatever he'll win
if you're going against biden where this
very strange
uh
like uh a versus b versus c
uh like uh you know prisoner's dilemma
type thing where it's like okay and so
when i was
uh on this panel with chris christie
chris christie said look generic
republican beats uh joe biden yeah and i
looked at chris and i said
i may agree with you but a generic
republican cannot win your primary
yeah so
this is like the order of operations is
that if you get trump
then joe says only i can defeat trump
and then like meanwhile in both cases 82
running
yeah it's like we can't he'll be 82 in
2024 um trump will be 77. yeah trump we
got to figure that out too
i mean desantis is in his 40s so he's
pretty likeable well i mean he's
well-liked
he's popular yeah he's very popular he's
popular i'd say he's he's probably a
republican strongest yeah trump a
non-trump candidate uh i just am of the
opinion that if trump runs no it'll run
yeah
see you know it's like you have he'll
end their career
that's what will happen yeah it's
it's much more prudent and intelligent
for them to be like look i'm going to
sit the cycle out
of something he could be
in this glide back he can be the next
president that would be the
smartest i said the exact same freaking
thing
for comedians too and this is maybe one
reason i naturally sympathize i've been
on camera
hundreds of hours yeah over the last
number of years so the odds of my
[ __ ] up
are a hundred percent i [ __ ] up
yesterday
last night
it's killing me the anxiety
uh well tell me about that i did a dumb
drinking podcast at barstool last night
and
i think i might have come off like a
jerk
so
kill him so tell me about this anxiety
you feel after the fact um
well seeing myself on camera i'm like
jesus christ and especially if i was
drunk on camera like ah
shut up yeah [ __ ] you you know
that's not a good look
that's
the funny thing is too is i knew that's
what i was doing i signed up to do that
i was like this would be funny to get
drunk on camera well do you know you're
a pissed off [ __ ] drunk no i'm not
usually not something happened last
night i was chirping
okay i got it but it's also just the
hangover anxiety today
you know how that is but you but you've
seen the footage i i'm not much of a
drinker no
i saw some of the footage on the way
here
that's not a good feeling no
i don't know it's the worst feeling in
the world when i've seen footage that i
regret it i'm like oh no and then the
comments joe rogan actually gave me some
of the best advice i've ever gotten
don't look at the comments i mean
that was literally easy to say i know
literally joe rogan's advice no
everyone's like don't read the comments
it's hard not to
they might have been right the comments
might have been right yesterday i'll
give them that oh wait they can't know
their comments are right look at this
again man it's like you you just uh
you're like unusually
um self-critiquing
yeah i hate myself
[Laughter]
what proportion of comedians hate
themselves i think all of them
it's pretty high yeah but then also the
other side of it is you love it you're
like ego
crazy and also you don't like yourself
like i've been grappling with this a
little bit because
i'm a very fairly
serious figure i suppose you know i've
written some serious books about
technology and the economy and our
dysfunctional political system so there
are people on my team
that say like look man you gotta like
like
toe a careful line in terms of the humor
because the last thing you want to do is
become like the haha like can't take him
seriously
joke figure
but then there's part of me that's like
look at this point comedians are the
most trusted figures in american life
and that there's almost no way out of
this that doesn't involve
uh
channeling that energy and humor into
something that's both honest and
positive
like i mean i mean don't listen to your
team
do whatever you want that's what people
want is someone genuine
that's why trump gets away with
everything
everyone's like
i feel like he's being honest though you
know
well that the word is authentic that's
what yeah it's like
that he's himself he seems to be
authentically phony
which is at least
somewhat honest compared to most
politicians and that is what most
americans have concluded is i'd rather
the authentic [ __ ]
than the
phony good person yeah and we do such a
bad job of
pushing each other to the other side
like i say all the time man the biggest
recruitment arm for the republicans is
democrats
i don't know what yeah it's a bummer we
need mcconaughey
all i do is travel the whole country
that's another reason why comedians get
[ __ ] yeah is because you've been all
over the place red state blue state
small town college town big city and it
turns out everyone's pretty good
as a person
in personally you find out in person
they're good yeah like i was i was in
mississippi two days ago
great
what are we talking about they're great
i don't know individually everyone's
pretty cool
and it doesn't matter where you are
i had the same experience running for
president i went small towns
uh midwest south northeast yeah i'll
actually say a quote to you someone i
was in alabama
and then this uh here's a quote from
alabama all right and uh so that and
then what got me in trouble last time
okay
this guy comes up to me and he's like
mr yang
i don't agree with you on a whole hell
of a lot
but you got a set of balls on you sir
and i respect that a great deal like
right out i was like well thank you
sorry that's actually like a really
positive set of it right yeah you know
talking to you shane i mean
you had an extraordinary perspective
when it was happening to you but like
you know now you just
you know you seem to have the healthiest
perspective on it ever i mean most
people would still you know be harboring
something but you you don't feel like
you have any any of that
no i don't i don't there's a couple
people
there's a couple people i don't you know
i'd still be upset with but even
even people that like
trashed me
if they i've had people come up and say
sorry and it's like immediately i'm like
great
thank you
i get it i've i've talked [ __ ] on
everyone
so when people talk [ __ ] on me i'm like
yeah i probably i have that coming a
little bit
i've kind of taken on this sort of jedi
like [ __ ] just rolls off my back kind of
thing would have been funny if you talk
[ __ ] about me
he would have killed me
that would have killed me that would
have been funny
maybe i would have done it had it been
if i'd known it was gonna be funny now
yeah no
everyone would have been like you might
have won
yeah you know are there people i i see
as like malignant and destructive and
like please please go away like yes
um yeah they exist yeah of course you
know and i think their ranks are
multiplying and this is one of the
destructive things too is that if you
start treating everyone like hey you get
off stage you get off stage you get off
stage as people are multiplying it's
like no we have to distinguish between
people who are like genuinely awful
toxic destructive hateful yeah you have
to because otherwise you keep kicking
everyone off stage they're going to
start they they link up
all of a sudden you've got actually
somewhat reasonable people that you
executed for no reason yes teamed up
with trump team not you know trump's i'm
not trying to throw it no
i don't want to ruin my boy trump's good
name
do you imitate him by the regular yeah
part of it too is like you know it's
like these social media platforms have
become
just like natural homes for people's
negative sentiments so if someone saw
your thing and were like hey that's fine
they're not going to be like love this
yeah someone's gonna of course slide you
so just you know let this be like the
you know one of the things is like
pretty much everyone
everyone still loves you
[Laughter]
and i've also had this experience two
million times
it's like um
most people have no idea that whatever
you're upset about is happening
now the that time when like the entire
uh western civilization turned on you
yeah people noticed that they got me
they all know what's that you know it's
funny i lived in it
i lived in spain for i taught english in
spain for a little and so i still had
these spanish teachers that i was
friends with and then i didn't talk to
them for like three years then i got snl
when i was on the news in madrid they
were like racist comic
like
they all started hitting me on whatsapp
like
shane what the what happened like you're
racist i was like
locieto
amigos
the important thing man is that you know
you're uh thriving you're a human being
you you're moving on you're still making
people laugh yes
and everybody's tough people forget
people forget they forgot the next week
yes and i had to live with it you know
that's how it goes
but
hopefully i do stand up so i can every
night
yeah
yeah yeah awesome hey
thank you for real like when you called
back then
meant a lot
hey thanks
thank you
you